Is organizing therapeutic for you?
Are you a messy person who likes to organize?
Join the club
As strange as it sounds, it is possible
Messiness and laziness might go hand in hand
But they also might be having an impact
on your mental and physical health
Enter a messy room
and you'll be sure to find objects
cluttered all over the place
Like it's a garage sale instead of a living room
A messy habitat can affect you so badly
your sleep is negatively impacted
living you stressed out
When you get to this point,
What can you do?
Organize of course
Organizing and putting things in place
can be therapeutic.
It helps you zone out for a while
and allows for some much needed silence for your mind.
As a result,
your sleep becomes better
and your stress level decrease.
According to some studies,
having too much of a mess around us
bombards our senses with excessive stimuli
This in turn, increases our inability to relax
because of our constant elevated stress levels.
The natural decline of cortisol,
the hormone that controls stress is hindered.
Our stress is an important part of our daily lives
because it keeps us alert.
Too much of it leaves us unable to relax
or sleep properly at the end of the day.
While this is all well and good
for the messy people of the world
what if you're a neat person
who's experiencing stress?
You don't have to be a messy person
to use organizing as a form of relaxation.
Organizing doesn't have to mean cleaning.
For example,
think of reorganizing a bookshelf.
Doing so could be as satisfying as cleaning the entire room.
It could also be a way of feeling in control
of your surroundings, activities or more.
According to research done in a field of occupational health,
you experience less stress when
you feel you have control over your work.
In the age we live in, it's a great achievement to be in control.
Also, organizing doesn't always have to pertain
to higher bedroom lux
you can gain a sense of control
by organizing your calendar for the next month,
right down to the tiniest detail
Rearranging your closet or organizing your school notes.
The recurring factor is instilling order.
Which the human brain is wired to respond positively to.
It's easier for our brains to deal with order.
Enabling us to take better care of
other aspects of our lives.
A great way to reduce anxiety or stress before you sleep,
is to organize things that are important to remember.
If you find you cant sleep,
you could try writing a to-do list for the next day.
or, arranging your school books according to size or class.
These activities are effective because
they help you relax, and stop you
from worrying of what's keeping you awake.
It's easier to sleep better after organizing
instead of trying to just fall asleep when you're stressed.
Simply put,
it's easier to sleep when you have a sense of control.
Symmetry, patterns and similarities are things
the brain recognizes and feels aesthetically pleased towards.
By organizing and putting things in order,
you'll feel a sense of familiarity and calmness.
Resulting in pleasing you and your mind.
If you enjoy organizing and have always wondered why it helped you relax,
we hope this video explained why.
Even you don't relate to this,
try it out for yourself and see if there are benefits.
Do you like to organize things to help you relax?
Leave a comment below.